bonjour à tous heureuse de vous
retrouver avec valérie de bord comme
porte parole des républicains pour une
journée importante à lendemain d'une
journée importante donc au lendemain de
ce premier tour de la primaire de la
droite et du centre qui a connu le
succès nous n'aurions peut-être pas
autant mais sur lequel si vous le
permettez nous allons revenir alors où
nous nous exprimons le résultat donné
par la haute autorité donne les chiffres
suivants sur 9545 bureaux de vote
dépouillés sur lesdits 1228
le résultat est de 3 millions 987 1948
votants soit près de 4 millions c'est
donc la consécration d'une très belle
séquence démocratique pour la droite et
le centre
je voudrais dès maintenant remercier au
nom des républicains les plus de 80
mille bénévoles qui se sont donné si je
puis dire sans compter dans les dizaines
de milliers donc de 10000 228 bureaux de
vote pour des moments difficiles car il
y a eu en effet beaucoup de monde qui se
sont présentés et qu'il soit ici saluer
pour leur travail et leur bénévolat je
le disais cette primaire a été un
formidable succès populaire pour la
droite qui voit par ce résultat les
principales réformes prônées par les
principaux participants être reconnu la
baisse de la fiscalité des charges la
réduction des fonctionnaires la
restauration de l'autorité de l'état
notamment validé vous l'avez bien
compris sans ambiguïté il s'agit donc
d'un signal très puissant en faveur
d'une rupture radicale avec la politique
conduite par la gauche
les français l'ont donc dit ils veulent
une alternance franches
la participation massive démontre à quel
point en effet ils veulent tourner la
page des années hollande
c'est une terrible douche froide pour la
gauche
elle concrétise la le ras-le-bol des
français et leurs aspirations au
changement après l'échec cuisant de la
politique menée et sur laquelle de toute
façon valérie parvenir un mot également
encore si vous le permettez sur ces
primaires ces primaires sont
l'aboutissement d'un cheminement et d'un
long cheminement de notre famille
politique
ceci a été rendu possible par l'unité
retrouvée de notre famille
cette unité nous la devons à nicolas
sarkozy nous voulons ici le remercier et
lui exprimer notre profonde gratitude
pour son engagement et son service au
niveau des républicains son énergie
pardon au service des républicains qu'il
aura contribué à créer en lieu et place
de l'ump son sens de l'intérêt général
et son autorité ont permis la page de
tourner la page des guerres fratricides
et de favoriser les conditions du
rassemblement
il laisse le mouvement en ordre de
bataille pour mener la droite à la
victoire pour 2017
au nom de tous les républicains
je veux ici lui redire notre gratitude
et pour bon nombre d'entre nous notre
attachement et notre fierté d'avoir
travaillé à ses côtés
merci merci brigitte bonjour à toutes et
à tous quelques mots effectivement pour
signifier que cette primaire qui est
évidemment pour la famille de la droite
et du centre une vraie réussite
elles marquent cette volonté
d'alternance et elle est pour françois
hollande est pour la gauche actuellement
au pouvoir
le marqueur de la volonté d'une
alternance forte et c'est également ce
que nous retenons nous allons donnez
nous notre famille politique une très
belle image avec des débats qui ont été
centrées sur les idées sur le fond et
non sur la forme
alors que beaucoup de commentateurs
beaucoup de gens attendaient voire pour
certains espéraient la forme au
détriment
fond on voit que nous sommes clairement
une famille qui éclaire sur sa ligne
d'idées sur sa ligne politique et qui a
un seul objectif mettre en place à la
tête de notre pays des décideurs qui
seront ceux de la droite et du centre
au mois de mai prochain dans cet état
d'esprit nous regardons avec étonnement
ce qu'elle choisit de faire françois
hollande le jour du premier tour de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
il a choisi de faire publier une tribune
par quelques-uns de ses amis dans le jdd
tribune appelant à la fin du holland
bashing très étonnant en fait de voir à
quel point cet homme sans faire sans
faire il s'enferme pardon dans une
espèce de boboïsation qui est
extrêmement nom proche des français
par contre nous venons de comprendre en
fait pourquoi et à quoi servaient les
dîners et les déjeuners de françois
hollande
clairement il reçoit à sa table des gens
qui après vont faire une tribune pour
expliquer que les gens sont méchants
avec lui que ce n'est pas gentil et que
monsieur 4% devrait être mieux traités
au delà du mépris que cela témoigne pour
un certain nombre de français ça démonte
surtout un décalage sans nom mais
vraiment sans nom entre 6 millions de
chômeurs 9 millions de précaires un
rapport du secours catholique la semaine
dernière qui démontre à quel point les
français sont en la difficulté des
jeunes qui ne trouvent pas d'activité
des étudiants qui s'en vont parce qu'ils
trouvent pas leur avenir en france et un
président de la république tellement
coupé des réalités que tout ce qu'il
sait faire c'est faire en sorte qu'une
cinquantaine de ses amis et bien publié
une tribune en la matière on voit que
cette présidence finissante n'est même
plus entre l'ombre et la lumière
mais clairement rentrés dans la pénombre
et cette pénombre s'illustre depuis la
semaine dernière avec les chiffres du
chômage
illustre de façon manifeste que
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage ne
sera pas au rendez vous puisque nous
avons sur le dernier trimestre une
augmentation de 0 1% et que surtout je
vous rappelle qu'un des enjeux majeurs
de la présidence de françois hollande
c'était je marche des jeunes et que
surtout le chômage des jeunes sur les
moins de 25 ans augmente de 1,2 pour
cent je vous rappelle les propos de
monsieur hollande au bourget s'il y a
seule chose sur laquelle je veux être
jugé
c'est sur la jeunesse bien la jeunesse
aura jugé en 2017 les jeunes seront
évidemment économiquement beaucoup plus
fragiles qu'en 2012
ça c'est le bilan catastrophique de
françois hollande et nous les
républicains nous allons inverser ce
bilan et inverser la courbe de l'espoir
pour que les soirs reviennent et
l'espoir qui revient c'est l'alternance
au mois de mai prochain
autre exemple aussi de cette politique
menée c'est le regard qui en est donnée
à à l'étranger cela ne vous aura
peut-être pas échappé mais néanmoins
nous souhaitons revenir sur la visite
la dernière visite du président des
états unis barack obama en europe pour
la deuxième fois consécutive
barack obama a snobé françois hollande
obama a préféré aller voir une
chancelière doté d'une popularité forte
est à la tête d'un pays fort
économiquement c'est la phrase qu'a
prononcé un conseiller diplomatique
français elle est dans toute sa réalité
d'une cruauté sans nom
et pourtant tout est dit déjà donc je le
rappeler à l'occasion d'une précédente
tournée européenne c'était en avril
barack obama avait préféré rendre visite
à nos homologues anglais britannique et
françois hollande avait dû lui se
contentait d'un entretien en présence de
plusieurs dirigeants européens à hanovre
cette fois ci le président obama s'est
rendu en grèce et en allemagne
voilà donc la preuve supplémentaire de
la faiblesse dans laquelle se trouve le
président de la république française est
par définition le pays dans son ensemble
sur le plan intérieur il a donc
reproduit les répercussions néfastes sur
l' influence de la france à
l'international
une faiblesse qui était d'ailleurs
rappelé vous déjà apparues au grand jour
lorsque angela merkel elle sonne
d'ailleurs avait négocié l'accord avec
la turquie sur les migrants jamais
françois hollande n'aurait dû tolérer ce
cavalier seul de l'allemagne
nous l'avions dénoncé à l'époque nous
leur disons aujourd'hui car nous le
payons chaque jour sur notre territoire
national comment et c'est vraiment la
question que de nous posons comment
françois hollande président de la
république at il pu supporter un nouveau
un tel camouflet diplomatique alors que
nos armées sont en première ligne en
syrie en irak et au mali pour combattre
le terrorisme islamiste
la france est la première puissance
militaire en europe et elle mérite donc
d'être considérée avec respect par notre
allié américain
au lieu de quoi bien sûr nous
apparaissons comme un pays européens de
seconde zone
françois hollande donc on le constate
est perçue par tous comme un dirigeant
faible et impopulaire
difficile dans ces conditions d'évoquer
l'avenir de l'europe avec un président
dont toutes les chancelleries du monde
le présente d'ailleurs comme étant un
président sortant
pour barack obama la porte d'entrée de
l'europe qui fut longtemps le royaume
uni mais une époque ça passait par la
france lorsque c'était nicolas sarkozy
et bien maintenant cette porte d'entrée
elle se situe en allemagne et non plus
en france une manière donc de signifier
à son successeur
où se situe le réel pouvoir européen et
dire que nous allons devoir supporter à
avec françois hollande qu'ils tiennent
la dragée haute à donald trump jusqu'au
mois de mai ce n'est pas vous l'aurez
compris pour nous rassurer nous
souhaitons également revenir sur une
décision extrêmement néfaste qu'a prise
le gouvernement la semaine dernière et
qui a été votée par le parlement le
parlement pardon le prélèvement à la
source
le prélèvement à la source fait partie
de ces réformes faites par monsieur
valls qui ont l'air d'être séduisante
intellectuellement mais qui seront très
clairement néfastes et négatives pour
les français pourquoi il n'ya en réalité
aucune simplification pour les ménages
dans cette réforme puisque de toute
façon ils seront obligés de faire une
déclaration correctives par rapport à ce
qui aura été établie donc le gain en
termes de simplification administrative
et parfaitement nul
deuxième chose et c'est parfaitement
inadmissible c'est une façon pour
l'administration fiscale de se décharger
sur les entreprises de cette déclaration
est donc beaucoup d'entreprises
notamment des pme des tpe s'en font
l'écho
c'est un surenchérissement des charges
pour les entreprises qui vont devoir et
bien faire ce travail à la place de
l'administration fiscale et faire en
sorte et bien d' établir l'ensemble des
déclarations
c'est à la fois un transfert de charges
et c'est parfaitement inadmissible
ensuite on voit bien que la crainte de
nombreux salariés et celle de la
possibilité pour un certain nombre
d'employeurs de connaître la réalité de
leur situation personnelle et la
situation personnelle d'un français avec
l'administration fiscale n'a pas à être
connu par l'ensemble des personnes qui
sont dans son entreprise et notamment
par son employeur sa situation
personnelle sa situation familiale ce
qui le lit ou pas à ses enfants à ses
conjointe à son conjoint pardon n'a pas
à être connu et on voit que c'est une
crainte importante qu'exprime
effectivement un certain nombre de
personnes
nous demandons et nous abolirons cette
mesure quitte à la fois est un imparfait
gadget mais qui en plus
et dangereuse pour les ménages nous en
sommes parfaitement convaincu quelques
mots peut-être juste pour dire que nous
avons donc un deuxième tour que nous
demandons à chacun est bien de se
préparer de renforcer cette dynamique
d'une deuxième tour nous avons
aujourd'hui un formidable succès et ce
formidable succès du premier tour doit
évidemment se conclure également sur le
second tour la droite et le centre ont
parlé ils parlent haut et fort et ils
doivent parler jusqu'au mois de mai
prochain et jusqu'au mois de juin
prochain puisque nous aurons après
l'étape des élections législatives qui
donnera à notre président la majorité
qui lui permettra de mettre en place les
réformes nécessaires pour que enfin ce
pays soit gouverné
oui j'ai salué valérie vient de le faire
à l'instant à nouveau la bonne tenue de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
nous attendons aussi maintenant avec
impatience la primaire de la gauche je
ne sais pas si ça s'appellera la gauche
et le centre
en tout cas nous les attendons et puis
peut-être aussi un petit mot pour la
candidature qui est passé pratiquement à
pratiquement mais qui a fait un peu
pschitt de monsieur macro et qui luisent
donc souhaite se présenter aux primaires
mais nous ne pouvons pas quand même ne
pas souligner et valérie de bord vient
de rappeler la politique désastreuse de
ce gouvernement dont emmanuel macron est
le coauteur plus que nous avons dépassé
vous le savez le million de chômeurs que
notre croissance est en berne que la
confiance a disparu que monsieur macron
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
puis ministre de l'économie a porté
cette politique
le matraquage fiscal des classes
moyennes atteinte et qui ils veulent
présenter et se présenter comme le
renouveau et bien un nouveau boulot ici
dire que à force de critiquer la vie des
partis et quand en plus on prétend
représenter le renouveau sans avoir été
élu
je propose un peu de modestie à tout un
chacun car que nous fait-il en ce moment
si ce n'est créé lui-même un parti
politique
et que fera t-il s'il n'a pas d'élu à
ses côtés alors avant de critiquer la
démocratie qui est tout simplement le
pouvoir des citoyens qui ont élu leurs
représentants et avant de prétendre à la
plus haute fonction
je propose à monsieur macro de regarder
aussi l'avis de plus près nous ne le
saurons que l'encourager à participer à
des primaires qui si il est si sûr de
lui pour avancer ni de gauche ni de
droite
nous attendons le résultat la primaire
de la gauche est une primaire je pense
ouverte
eh bien nous nous félicitons de la tenue
des primaires de la droite et du centre
sur nos engagements et nos convictions
que nous sommes fiers devant vous de
représenter aujourd'hui je vous remercie